House Democrats escalating their
impeachment inquiry into president Trump
late Friday they issued a subpoena to
the White House for documents relating
to the whistleblower complaint they are
also requesting ukraine related
documents from vice president mike pence
it comes as another intelligence
official concerned about the president's
dealings with ukraine is reportedly
considering filing a second
whistleblower complaint mr. Trump
maintains he did nothing wrong and is
pushing back he says White House
cooperation with subpoena requests could
hinge on whether House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi takes a vote to formally launch
an impeachment impeachment investigation
Ben Tracy is at the White House this
morning with the latest Ben good morning
good morning so the White House is
resigned to the fact that this
impeachment inquiry is already underway
but the president wants House Democrats
to have to go on the record
formally supporting it because the White
House thinks that may hurt some of them
in vulnerable House districts meanwhile
the president is not backing down even
in the face of new evidence they're
trying to steal your vote they're trying
to steal your voice and steal your
country they're trying to steal your
country president Trump is playing both
offense and defense he now says asking
foreign governments to investigate Joe
Biden and his son hunter is not about
politics it's about doing his job but I
do care about corruption we are looking
at corruption we're not looking at
politics but when pressed if he has ever
asked a foreign country to investigate
anyone other than a political rival the
president could not recall China mr.
Trump claims he has an absolute right to
ask China and Ukraine to look into what
he calls the Biden's corrupt business
deals even though there is no evidence
of any wrongdoing by the Biden's the
former vice president fired back on
Friday let's focus on the problem focus
on this man what he's doing that no
president has ever done no president
president Trump still insists he did not
withhold 391 million dollars worth of
military aid to Ukraine to pressure them
to investigate Biden
this came out it was quid pro quo well
there was but text messages from the
president's own diplomats provided to
Congress tell a different story in one
message last month the top US diplomat
to Ukraine bill Taylor wrote I think
it's crazy to withhold security
assistance for help with a political
campaign
Gordon sunlit the Trump appointed US
ambassador to the EU then disagreed
saying I believe you are incorrect about
president Trump's intentions no quid pro
quos of any kind most congressional
Republicans are still backing President
Trump but in a Friday tweet Utah senator
Mitt Romney called the president's
actions seeking foreign help brazen
unprecedented and appalling there have
been discussions here at the White House
about the upsides of impeachment with
some administration officials believing
it will help rally the president's base
president Trump has said Democrats will
pay a tremendous price at the polls if
they do in Picchu Michelle all right Ben
Tracy thank you